we're well we design
solutions with the fourth of
the
marginalized so that includes your
persons with disabilities your
caregivers and etc
what if we could design something so
intuitive that you don't need to think
about it we wanted to do something like
this interactive part which has
something super easy
that we wanted to put up
easy for people to understand and relate
when they look at buttons saying no okay
this is on my shirt
right so when they look at it they
naturally intuitively already understood
it la and so we just put this so that
they could just immediately relate well
it's just a whole row but yeah it really
is just the whole role of it yeah
yeah it is
it's really this kind of differences
that we are really trying to like point
out and a lot of these
differences are very minor differences
people just think that this is only for
persons with disabilities people no
longer think about it that way anymore
people are able to understand that oh
okay actually this is very feasible for
me as well it's changing the way they
perceive things and i think i think that
is good progress in itself already
yeah i think that every single thing
that we're experiencing is a work of art
and it's a design it's it's with a it's
a it's with a thought it's with a design
thought
i think with design and the way we um
question all this like is there value in
design and all that i think at the end
of it what makes sense of it is the
integrity of it
i think integrity is something that you
know
um it's important
when we when we approach design right
[Music]
you